qu'elle soit porteuse de projets ou
dirigeants d'entreprises depuis 2003 les
femmes entrepreneurs de notre territoire
sont accompagnés et soutenus par
l'association créactive aujourd'hui 130
adhérentes se retrouvent plusieurs fois
par semaine pour des ateliers ou bien
des partages d'expériences en 15 ans
l'adn de l'association n'a pas changé et
vise même à se développer
paris saclay se développe donc ce serait
une bonne idée nous faire connaître des
femmes entrepreneurs du côté de la kek
est à 20 minutes d'ici et qui a une
belle dynamique au niveau
entrepreneurial
céline est décoratrice et a lancé son
activité de home staging il y a un an
elle aide les particuliers à vendre plus
facilement leur appartement ou leur
maison avec des astuces rangement et
décoration elle est atterrante a créé
active depuis 2015 on peut trouver des
réponses à ces questions en tant que
femme en tant qu'entrepreneur si on a
des difficultés à se motiver
dès qu'on a un petit rendez vous
kreactive on sait que voilà on va être
boostée et qu'on va retrouver l'énergie
nécessaire pour pour repartir sur de
bonnes bases pour sa journée on aimerait
beaucoup beaucoup à voir des femmes
entrepreneurs qui ont embauché des
salariés parce que c'est ça aussi la
typologie des femmes entrepreneurs en
france
elles créent leur emploi mais pas
forcément des emplois et ce serait bien
que son association on est aussi des
femmes qui ont développé leur entreprise
toutes les activités sont représentés au
sein de créactive qui est appelé à
grandir au cours des prochaines années